[Music]
nominations for the 92nd Academy Awards
have been announced and there are
definitely some major surprises and not
all of them are the good kind so let's
take a look at who did and who didn't
get nominated on the Quecha one of the
biggest surprises from the Oscar
nominations list this year is that cat's
got snug I'm just kidding
one of the most pleasant surprises comes
from Joker not that it got nobs which we
expected but it is the most nominated
film of the year with 11 and that
includes Best Picture adapted screenplay
and todd phillips for director and
joaquin phoenix for lead actor opps it's
only the second comic book movie to ever
score Best Picture not joining Black
Panther although Dark Knight does have
an honorary nomination in our hearts and
Joker is the only non certified fresh'
movie among the nine Best Picture
nominees so I guess who's laughing now
but also surprising is the amount of
major snub starting with Adam Sandler a
lot of people thought he was a sure bet
to earn his first ever Oscar nomination
for uncut gems but I guess that bets
been lost communi and then there's my
girl JLo after an amazing performance
and hustlers that earned her both Golden
Globe and SAG nominations
there's no Best Supporting Actress not
form the Oscars for her other snobs
include the PETA and young go I mean
neither of her performances from us got
a nomination and also Willem Dafoe's
eerily awesome performance in the
lighthouse was denied as well and
despite winning the Golden Globe for
Best Actor after two really strong
performances both Taron Egerton from
Rocket Man and Aquafina from The
Farewell got no love from the Oscars
isn't that wrong to lie and Eddie
Murphy's big return fueled by plenty of
awards love for dolomite is my name will
be halted with a complete shutout at the
Oscars maybe as our very own Mark Ellis
suggested on Twitter Eddie Murphy and
Adam Sandler should totally do a live
comedy special than night of the Oscars
but Jalen was a musical guest
but it's not all bad friends new year
new us so let's end this thing on a
positive note
just behind Joker's 11 nominations are
three films that each got ten
nominations the irishman Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and 1917 and Scarlett
Johansson earned her first ever Oscar
nomination for Best Actress in marriage
to
and her second for Best Supporting
Actress in judge Oh rabbit and parasite
the runaway leader on our official
awards leaderboard will have a chance to
add to that total with six Oscar
nominations including Best Picture and
bong joon-ho for Best Director and John
Williams the acclaimed composer whose
star wars scores are forever ingrained
in our hearts and ringtones got his 52nd
nomination for the rise of Skywalker as
he chases Walt Disney's all-time record
of 59 nominations damn
[Music]
the Oscars are Sunday February 9th and
once again going host las' this year so
maybe someone should give a call to Adam
Sandler and Eddie Murphy alright guys
it's time to get get over you now what
are your thoughts on the Oscar
nominations this year and raise your
hand if you think there's a lack of
diversity let us know all your thoughts
in the comment section and for more
oscars coverage check out Rotten
Tomatoes calm and if you don't want to
miss out on any future episodes at the
ketchup hit that subscribe button and
notification bell as always thank you
for watching the ketchup I'm now
surprised and we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]